and never look
backs and simply learn to get ahead jish
a civil engineer turned data scientist
who decided to Simply learn
possible with a course from a premier
[Music]
University true champion who upskilled
to win big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish change gears
pretty early in the race but PR wanted
to explore more to get ahead isar simply
learn from mechanical engineering to a
data analyst and a podcaster in his free
time transformation simply learn
industry
expert data
expert with a well structured Cod course
it felt like a piece of cake that is
simply awesome what's also awesome is
that longer didn't choose a quick fix he
just added data science into the
mix nithan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop nin from getting ahead what
an allrounder day night with flexible
learning you can always make it right
passion
situation
you too will find your way to get ahead
when you simply
learn simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
recording in progress the chat is open
can so my name is aay I'm from Simply
learn I am joining in from Bangalore uh
Karthik where are you joining as
from yeah so I am uh I'm from Senai so
I'm I work at Ford Motor Company I
manage the business analytics
team I would request the audience to put
in the chat from where they are joining
hi Satya hi good to know you're joining
usun aab hi
aab
nice
there
of
[Music]
Bangalore
Kolkata great great great great good to
see you all here today uh we have a wide
audience joining us from across the
country uh before we begin uh I would
like to welcome all of you to our
webinar today discover uh how to launch
your business analyst career 2024 I hope
I'm Audible and my screen is visible to
everybody I would request you to just
confirm that in the chat as
well great great thank you for the
confirmation uh let's begin uh before we
begin uh I would like to set some ground
rules uh please if you have any
questions during the session I would
request you to put it in the Q&A box
which is there below uh yes the session
is being recorded and you'll be getting
a followup email with the recording link
as well um if in order to get your
webinar certificate for attending today
you'll need to fill in the post webinar
survey which will come once you close
the webinar please fill in your details
and uh give your feedback and uh the
recording link and your certificate will
be delivered to your email U that's
about it please I request all of you to
post a question in the Q&A
box let me begin with introducing simply
learn simply is the world's number one
online boot camp uh we have been in the
training industry for about uh 14 years
now and we have taught to about 500,000
carers across 150 countries we have
about 40 plus global accreditions and we
have about 800 plus qualified trainers
working with us we provide doses on
different topics as you can see AI
machine learning data science business
analytics cloud computing devops and so
on
uh let me take you through the agenda
for today uh we obviously talking about
you about business analytics carers in
2024 and what this program offers you uh
how to how this program will get your
job ready and the ement steps to this
program and we'll have a Q&A session
which will be taken at the
end uh we welcome Mr Karthik today our
Mentor for today he's been an magnetics
manager with 18 years of experience and
12 years in the data science Industry
he's currently working at the Ford Motor
Company and I would request Kik to
please introduce
himself yeah thanks a so hello everyone
uh so I I'm currently working for Ford
Motor Company in their analytics
division so as the slide sees I have uh
totally 18 to 19 almost close to 19
years experience and I am a computer
science engineer and uh I hold a degree
in management so the last 12 years I
have mainly worked in data science and
again my I have worked on very kind
different kinds of projects like uh
reporting dashboarding to Advanced
machine learning data sciences and also
deep learning projects which I'm doing
off late so I'm happy to be part of this
meeting thanks thank thank you ktic
thank you for being here and it's an
honor to have you on there today moving
on let's begin with starting talking
with some of the business analytics
careers in
2024 uh karik so what exactly is
business analytics how do you define
business analytics in your
words so business analytics in simple
words is U the process of deriving
insights from data so uh for example
let's say a person is a marketing
analyst and one of the question that
comes up for him is uh did any of our
marketing campaigns work right recently
we ran this marketing campaign
so some he would mainly be involved in
gathering data and uh analyzing
consolidating and deriving insights from
it it could be something as simple as
exploratory analysis to regression or
any of the models to find whether the uh
campaign the marketing campaign was uh
successful or not right so that is just
one specific example so in the end you
need a different kinds of skills one is
uh how do we uh gather the data how do
we uh use the right technique so it
needs a blend of programming plus uh
statistical knowledge as well as
communication the communication is
important because the person would be
Comm would be telling their results uh
details explaining it to business and it
has to be in more business
understandable form so yeah those are
some skills that uh people in business
Antics great great great thank you uh so
Kik do you think that data has become
the most essential thing ever and it's
going to be even further going ahead yes
so especially in the last uh I would say
15 years or so I have been in analytics
for the last 12 years and I was also
part of data warehousing which in a way
it is like uh a way of how you store
data in a format to be consumed right so
uh data has been uh the volume of data
that we get has really uh grown uh
exponentially and there are some main
reasons uh one of the reasons is how you
are able to the other technologies that
have also grown how can you how can you
store large amount of data Big Data how
can you gather data from different
sources like uh like getting data from a
car right taking the case of Automotive
so initially it was like uh you did not
have any kind of digital devices but now
cars everything have sensors so they
detect uh
so they detect what kind of signals the
cars give where does the car move it's
like a mobile phone right you tracks
where it goes how long it is used what
features so uh again as per uh uh like
there is what this called the mor law so
Mor law is every two years the number of
transist on a chip doubles right so as a
result of that the computing power
storage power has vastly increased so
that is one major reason I see uh data
become
very crucial right and also there are
real life use cases that we see like
Netflix Amazon again how they use
analytics to improve their sales right
so Netflix almost 80% of their uh almost
80% of their uh Revenue comes from the
recommendations that they provide right
so yeah that's I see those are some
reasons that I see and also uh it's a
blend of different uh different skill
sets like I said programming and
statistics
uh and it's also it also requires
communication skills right the right
business domain knowledge is another
important thing so yeah that's one those
those are some key reasons I see why
data has become a
Essen thank you uh so uh can you take us
through some of the key skills that will
be needed for any business analyst or
data analyst in 2020 Pro yeah so like I
said
broadly uh it would be three key skills
uh and it's very broad so one of them
definitely is business domain knowledge
which again companies value a lot
because from the technical side a lot of
it is getting automated these days of
course you need to know how it is but
this the domain knowledge is very
crucial here understanding the business
and the technical skills like
understanding the mathematics behind it
uh and statistics are different
techniques that you use so here as it's
been mentioned linear regression
logistic right those are some basic
methods that they use for building model
it could be even more complex P that
they use to build it right so knowledge
of the math knowledge and as well as
programming skills you may need to use
SQL python R these kind of technologies
have become uh very common these days so
those are some crucial skills I can
broadly classify into and uh yeah like
communicating your results to business
that's another important thing that they
look for how do you communicate the
results in a more understandable form so
those are some key skills that's
required and again recently we have seen
a lot of uh Buzz around large language
models and how they are automating uh a
lot of things right so yeah keeping in
touch with tech technology changes and
uh staying on top of it is very crucial
here got thank
you so uh as a business analyst like
what are the different key roles you
think is going to be in demand or what
do you think is going to be coming up in
the next year or so can you take
us yeah so uh again some of the roles
that are listed here are more domain
specific like financial analyst right
people who work in a financial domain
supply chain analyst so supply chain is
one of the most important things for
manufacturing companies Right Automotive
or fmcg manufacturing so how do you
ensure that uh right set of goods are
available how do you ensure the
inventory is less how do you ensure they
are stocked right so all of these need a
kind of mathematical models to be
involved and optimizing each of these
right so definitely I think uh the years
going forward a sound understanding of
the mathematical techniques uh for a
data scientist or a uh machine learning
and one more area is how do you deploy
these things right so maybe as a
business analytics may not involve it
but you're looking for a career in data
science uh or a machine learning
engineer you should see how can you
deploy what you build how can it run in
production at uh uh and is scalable
right so those are some skills that they
definitely look for in the uh in this
year in 2024 and also like I said I
think generative a is a very uh Hot
Topic now people
are trying to get an idea of what it is
essentially and how can it be tuned to
help companies right a lot of things can
automator or uh it can uh it can be uh
you know the processes can be speeded up
so yeah I think llm is Genera a and
large language model is another
important
area so before moving on I just launched
a p for the audience I would request you
all to punch in your responses just ask
how much experience do you have uh it
can be currently studying 3 years 0 to 5
years or more than 5 years of experience
so I would request you to please punch
in your responses I'll keep the poll
open for another 10 seconds and then
close
it I would request all of you to punch
in your
answers I just stop the thank
you so as I can see most of our audience
uh is more than five years of experience
and some of them are 0 to 3 years and0
to 5 years as well and about 30% of
audience is going to
start thank
you moving on uh I have another poll
coming up so now that you know that the
skills
and what are the different career paths
you can take I would quickly run another
poll uh so what's really uh stopping you
from
uh becoming a business analytics expert
uh is it that you are not finding a
comprehensive program uh you I you don't
have practical exposure to become job
ready or are you you finding it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos or your work schedule doesn't
allow enough time uh so I'll just
quickly launch the poll so you can just
punch in your answers it's a multiple
choice you can put in whatever problems
you have so you may have you may not you
may have been having more than a one
problem out of this so request all of
you to punch in your
responses uh is it that you cannot find
a comprehensive curriculum is it that
you don't have enough practical exposure
to become a job ready uh you're finding
it difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos or your work schedule just
doesn't allow you enough time for
learn I'll just keep the poll open for
at the 5
Seconds I request all of you to pun in
your
responses and
I
great thank you all for your responses
so I can see the audience uh are have a
lot of problems uh they are not able to
find a curriculum they don't have
practical exposure is a most common
answer uh and the work schedule doesn't
allow them enough time great thank you
all for your responses so to overcome
all these problems uh simp has come up
with a unique program called the
business analytics for strategic
decision making it is in collaboration
with the IIT
RI and in collaboration with IBM as well
so this program uh is about for six
months duration if you invest about 10
to 15 hours a week uh you'll be able to
finish the program in about six months
uh it has a comprehensive curriculum
with an industry aligned learning path
uh it has integrated case studies which
will give you practical experience it
has also online live virtu classrooms
where you can interact with the peers
and your instructors it is also flexible
to fit your lifestyle and
schedu uh at the end of the program
you'll be getting a certificate from I
RI uh and also post completion
certificates from IBM uh we will be
having IBM hackathons ask meting
sessions and master classes from I
faculty as well we also provide job
assist career assistance
program and as we all know I L is one of
the most renowned and recognized
universities in India and worldwide as
well uh it has over 175 year history it
has over 8,000 students at at any point
under 500 faculty and the IIT RI
Department of management studies ranks
about the first in the research and
professional practices in the 2020
ranking coming to the IBM Advantage this
course as I mentioned is in
collaboration with IBM as well uh you
will be having exclusive ha pons and ask
me anything sessions by IBM uh master
classes by
IBM faculty as well and Industry will'll
be also getting some of the additional
coures along with this
course coming to the eligibility of this
program uh first and foremost you need
to have a drive to apply to business
analytics Concepts in the real world
problems uh preferably five years of
experience would be do great if you're
planning to join this program
and the good news is you don't need any
prior coding experience of
Technology uh so uh I think I have quick
question for you uh what do you think
about the first eligibility criteria
like you need becoming a business
analyst how important it is to have
interest in that field and like how
would you guide our your learners
today yeah so uh again a drive to apply
business analytics in real world problem
so so uh that's something very crucial
again I would say analytics it is partly
science as well as partly it involves
creative side as well by creative side I
mean how can you uh how can you modify
your models or how can you build models
that are more appropriate and are more
accurate right so the ability to apply
to business and to actual business
problems is very important your domain
knowledge that's where like I mentioned
earlier domain knowledge is very crucial
I here in helping you succeed at this
right uh and yeah again coding
experience that's one more important
area uh I think uh people who understand
business they also need to have some
basic coding uh knowledge to get into
analytics so yeah so that's what I
want so how does this program prepare
you uh we have a very comprehensive
program lined up for you guys uh
beginning with an orientation session uh
where you'll be taken through all the uh
know hows of the program and how what
we'll be learning and uh followed by
foundations of business analytics
module again after that we have a
statistical analysis for business
decision making uh followed by an explor
data analysis and visualization using R
uh Predictive Analytics for business
prescriptive analytics for business and
data science and machine learning for
decision making
business analytics for decision making
caption project the caption project
we'll be discussing few more slides as
well apart from these modules we also
have some electives we have academic
master classes from I RI faculty we have
industry master classes from IBM we also
have data analysis with python by IBM
mathematical optimization for business
Problems by IBM data visualization with
python IBM and we also have a new module
added which is generative AI just like
Kik mentioned that one of the most Hot
Topic right now generative AI we have
add that as Kik can you just
uh comment on like the comprehensiveness
of this program and how generative I is
changing how we work these
days yeah so uh and I think like I said
earlier uh each of the steps mentioned
here are very crucial to get us solid
grasp uh again you would start with
simple exploratory analysis and you
would be taught uh you can pick up on
commonly used analytics tools like
python or R these are some commonly used
python is of course it is much more
widely used uh based on that also you
would need to have a good grasp of
mathematical Concepts and then you can
move on to the next steps like they said
pred predictive prescriptive analytics
so in then business wants to know what
they should do uh they need to be
provided with some steps on uh how how
they should progress and how to achieve
certain results right so that's where
prescriptive analytics comes and machine
learning again it's like a way of
automating things how can you uh create
some set of steps uh that helps you
achieve uh certain outcomes right so
that's where machine learning is the
input would of course be the data the
clean data transform and the output
would be uh kind of an automated process
that uh would predict with a good
accuracy whatever uh business outcomes
are required right and similarly the
generative AI I think that's another key
concept that uh is required so
especially in the last one year this
term has gained a lot of uh uh traction
and uh I think rightly so because uh it
is being used to automate a lot of areas
and uh yeah that is another important
skill uh that is required and I think
it's uh it's good that those skills are
being
Incorporated got got thank you for
that moving on uh these are some of the
tools and Frameworks that you'll be
learning these include Excel TBL powerbi
python or myl arthic can you just take
us through these tools like how
important are these tools to be learned
to become a
business yeah so first of all maybe
starting with the database right you
have my SQL is a very commonly used uh
database they call this rdbms relational
database management system so this is
where you store and query data in a uh
in a normalized form uh so MySQL is I
would say one of the tools that's being
used widely uh another key area in
analytics is dashboarding and generating
business Insight so dashboarding very
simply is like uh like you can think of
like charts or graphs that help bu
business uh track certain key metrics
and I think things from my Tableau is
one of the key business intelligence
tool and same with Microsoft powerb
powerb is another very important tool
that is gaining traction offl so yeah
tblo and we there's also click view
which is another important dashboarding
tool right and Microsoft Excel it's a
versatile tool it can be used for
multiple purposes it can be either for
uh uh it can be used either for simp
uh analysis to uh even even try and
prepare some dashboards which are used
by business so Microsoft Excel is
another important one and python in
terms of programming language in ter
machine learning I think python is one
of the most widely used tools uh and uh
yeah I think it will be very helpful if
people can uh can get a basic
understanding of this tool even as they
are starting their
course moving on uh we had mentioned
about the Capstone project uh which will
be included in the program uh so
Capstone project is a project which you
will be mimicking a real life business
problem and you'll be able to solve it
along with your with the help of your
instructors uh obviously it will help
you add value to your resume and uh uh
say that you have worked on a problem
and obviously they get you the job
interview that you're looking for or
getting
hang on hands-on experience about
projects as well so this project will be
included in the program uh these are
some of the projects the examples that
are included in the program it's
understanding our for business analytics
impact of training on employee
satisfaction is another project which we
have uh there is another project called
client portfolio classification and
there are many more such projects as
part of the program which should be
under we we also have some of the global
leaders as program advisers these
include Professor raes tun Sharma and
Professor Amit
upad all these will be part of your
program as
well these are some of the learner
outcomes this is sudip go how we've had
12 years of experience in business
development and then he mov he up the
course from I RI and now he's uh
starting his own business uh many this
is just one of the stories which we have
uh you can maybe go on a website and
check out from such
stories uh and explore how our Learners
have benefited from this program moving
on apart from the program we also
provide job assist services to our
Learners uh these include free access to
expert webinars uh which will help you
plan your career uh you can also work
with real world projects across
Industries and create a portfolio of
projects uh and the job assist obviously
contains a portal you'll be access you
can access to a portal where you'll be
able to apply to jobs uh we also help
with resume writing services where you
can improve your resumés and make
it great to get land that perfect
interview for you which you always been
looking for and we also provide
one-on-one mentoring Services where uh
mentors will be able to help you and
take Mo interviews for you and give you
feedback so that you can improve the
next
time so now that you know what all we
are offering what the program is
offering I would like to quickly run
another poll that if you are interested
to enroll in our business analytics
program from IIT rot key uh it's a
simple yes or no you can punch in your
answers and and
uh we have quite a
audience today or very interactive so I
can see a lot of calls being answered
and it's great to know that we have an
active audience
today I'll keep the poll open for
another 5 seconds and
shut I request all of you to punch in
your PO
answers
great great great thank you I'll end
the thank you all as I can see almost
70% of our audience is interested in
taking up the program that's
good moving on I'll quickly run you
through the enrollment steps for this
program uh there are three simple steps
uh step one uh you need to submit an
application uh you can do that by
sending us an email at ask us@ simply
learn.net
our team at simply learn and I Ry will
review your application in the Second
Step once all your alib criteria and
education background is verified uh we
will send you an admission me in the
final step so those who are interested
uh our next cohort starts on the 29th of
November this month and the induction
session will be on 29th and the classes
will start in the month of January so
let me tell you that we we have limited
number of seats I'll quickly post the
link to the course page in the chat so
that you can have access and explore the
course in detail again coming to the
program fees the program is priced at 1
lak 149,000 in India uh we also provide
Emi financing
options uh it's starting at 571 rupees a
month if you have any other queries
related to the program you can always
email us at ask us simply learn.net and
our team will get back to you at the
earliest so how soon do you plan to
enroll in this program we have another
poll uh is it immediately or within 3
months within 6 months or after 6 months
so this will help us better uh
understand our audience better so I
would request you all to please punch in
your answers in this screen
how soon we plan to enoll in our
business business analytics course by
I I request all of you to punch in your
answers keep the poll open for another 5
seconds and
close I would meanwhile I would request
uh everybody to post your questions in
the Q&A box so that we can take it up in
the coming
slides thank you all for your
responses yes motion it is of six
months uh coming to Q&A sessions I'll
just quickly run through if you have any
questions uh
so bushan we also provide Emi options as
I mentioned it starts from 5,000 a month
uh you can always send us an email at
ask us at simply learn.net and our team
will be getting back to you with more
details uh the next batch is scheduled
to start in uh the orientation is going
to be held this month the 29th of
November and the classes will begin for
the same on in the month of
January it is a six-month post RIT so if
you invest like 10 to 15 hours a week
you'll be able to complete the program
in six months along with the
projects uh do we have any questions for
Kik our Mentor
today yes RIT we'll have uh
weekend classes as well uh we have live
sessions on the weekends and we also
have pre-recorded videos which you can
watch at any time you wish to class
timings adti uh we will we we have
separate cohorts so you can send us an
email and depending on your choice you
can set the class timings and we'll
inform you about the class
timings so karik I have a question for
you um so I'm very intrigued by these
Motor companies like and you are working
in one of them so how does your day look
like what exactly like you can just
brief us what exactly you
your yeah so my I am like I said I'm a
data analytics and uh machine learning
engineering manager so mainly our day
mostly consists of so I'm also playing
the role of a product owner so uh our
days would generally consist of how do
we identify the right business problem
so I involve uh I have I discuss with
the business teams to understand what
are their problems what are the way
forward and we also create a road map as
to what are the key areas that we need
to accomplish and try to see if a
problem is really worth working on right
so does it add good uh business value
and uh does it help in Saving cost or
add adding Revenue so those are some
things we take into account to Ure the
business value so once the business
value is understood we try to see how
the problem can be solved what are the
data uh Dimensions that we need where
can we obtain them from right so those
are some things more from the
brainstorming perspective understanding
the data and also work with other teams
mine is also a cross functional team I
work with different teams so uh uh so I
it's to understand where the data is and
most importantly what technique can we
use right so start with some exploratory
analysis and then go to more complex
machine learning models and finally once
it has reached a certain stage how can
we deploy that model and ensure it
seamlessly runs on a regular basis right
so those are the steps that you
generally do for any machine learning or
analytics projects and uh yeah like I
said also deriving the business value is
very important because uh that's how we
justify and I also manage a team of
close to 7 to eight people uh how data
sent so uh yeah discussions with them
mentoring them handholding them those
are some areas that I work on great
great sounds very interesting and uh the
amount of data I'm sure you must be
getting like for cars and uh other
things like must be immense like because
nowadays most of the cars have the maybe
like a th I don't know how many sensors
but each of
them must be gathering so much data that
there's a lot to play with
right yes yeah so again my area is not
directly related to but we partly get
some data on this so like I said earlier
how do you track where the vehicle is
the location of the vehicle those are
some things uh that's being done very uh
on a large scale so that's again is a
good classic example of data explosion
the digital uh uh the uh digital
transformation that's happening at a lot
of companies so so yeah I think those
are some data weuse some big data
analytics platforms to uh to process
such
data uh
I I'm not able I don't think that we
have any more questions for today
uh yes buan you can unroll for your
enroll for this course there's no
worries
uh
uh we have one last poll before we end
the session today uh if you need any
assistance uh to enroll for this program
you can simply punch in in yes I have
launched the poll uh do you need any
assistance to enroll uh you can quickly
uh punch in your responses uh if you
don't need any assistance you can
directly go to the program page fill in
your fill in the form and our team will
get back to you immediately and if you
need any assistance please punch in a
yes so those who have punch in yes uh
you can expect a call back from us uh
immediately I'll keep the poll open for
another five minutes 5 Seconds
sorry I request all of you to please
punch in your
responses thank you all I'll end the
poll
that's it for today uh I would like
thank our Mentor for today Mr caric for
joining us and giving us his time it was
really interesting session and we really
got to learn a lot about this different
skills and the roles that are needed for
business sist I would request all of you
uh that have joined him today uh please
have a look at the link which I've
shared in the chat I'll paste it again
for every everybody so that you can
explore the program and uh see what all
it offers as we already discussed today
and I would like to thank karik for
joining us today thank you karik for
thank you thank you a it was a pleasure
joining
us thank you all for joining us today I
wish you a very good night and a great
week ahead thank you I'll end the webin
thank you thank
you